a warning the content of this story may
be disturbing for some of you
last fall a frozen dead body was brought
into this portland hotel then tickets
were sold and the ticket holders were
let into this room while they watched
this dead body be cut into and taken
apart examined for a pain audience some
reporters from a local tv station from
seattle caught wind of this and secretly
filmed the whole thing at times the
professor encourages attendees to poke
and prod the body they found that this
dead body had belonged to a man named
david saunders a world war ii veteran
from louisiana he had died last year and
had chosen to donate his body to science
but here he was a few months later on
display at a public event in an oregon
hotel where people paid hundreds of
dollars to watch this live autopsy these
weren't doctors or med students in
attendance these were just everyday
people who had bought tickets to the
oddities and curiosities expo it is
chris hard to believe that this kind of
thing could actually be
legal this is not what david saunders
signed up for he donated his body to be
used for training doctors and improving
medicine not for a live public autopsy
with 500 tickets
how is this possible how can someone
just purchase a dead body when it comes
to bodies some critics have called the
wild west out there that there really
are no rules i got really curious about
this industry and i wanted to dive in
and understand what is going on here as
usual it turned into kind of a deep dive
suddenly i was digging through documents
and suddenly i'm looking into the
details of organ transplants and
cadavers and funeral homes and what i
learned through all of this is that once
you're done with your body there is a
thriving market of people who want to
get their hands on it
the owner is selling body parts
the fbi says grizzly details
before we dive fully into cadavers let's
do a commercial break so i can thank
today's sponsor which is better help i'm
really grateful for better help for
supporting this channel and supporting
the work that i do but i'm also a
believer in what they are doing which is
making therapy more accessible to the
masses but if you've ever tried to look
for a therapist you will know that it's
not easy better help is a platform where
you can search their network of over 20
000 therapists and because it's not
bound to your geography this is
available worldwide it's a really quick
sign up you take a little quiz so that
betterhelp can assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional and you can start
communicating with someone like within
48 hours it's not a self-help like
crisis hotline it is legitimate therapy
done securely on the internet you can
change it anytime and you can message
your therapist it's more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available so if you
want to join the over 2 million people
who are taking charge of their lives
with better help go to betterhelp.com
johnny harris clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gets
you 10
off your first month so thank you better
help for sponsoring let's dive back into
cadavers
battery's not included
[Applause]
okay dead bodies never thought i'd be
going into dead bodies but here we are
let's just say one thing up front
doctors like to learn how to be doctors
using real human bodies like medical
students can't really practice hip
replacements on living people so they
use the bodies of dead people which are
called cadavers oh and this isn't a new
thing studying dead bodies can be traced
back like thousands of years to ancient
egypt and greece but then it had a
comeback in like the 16th and 1700s in
europe working on dead bodies allowed
physicians to actually see how bodies
are organized the most important factor
in the study of health and disease is
man himself to understand how diseases
spread which in turn benefits the living
there was such a demand for dead bodies
that the government in england actually
passed this murder act that said any
murderer who is hanged or executed
could be given to a medical school and
studied and then to keep filling the
demand they actually like started
hanging more criminals so that they
could have bodies to study but demand
was still too high higher than the
supply of hanged criminals which led to
the rise of grave robbing
[Music]
people were robbing graves in the name
of science and it was seen as a big
problem but then again there's this
tension here which is like they're using
these bodies to learn to like understand
how to do medical procedures and that's
better for humans eventually expanded
the law to say anyone who was unclaimed
didn't have family come claim them could
be used as cadavers but even still
during the 16th 17th and 1800s when all
of this medical progress is happening
the demand for cadavers totally
outstripped the supply there was not
enough dead bodies and then in the 1960s
america is like wait a minute did
someone say supply and demand i smell a
free market why don't we just
give people the option to donate their
bodies so that we don't have to just
wait for criminals and unclaimed people
and some people were like yeah but now
we have these synthetic models that are
really good and they're just like bodies
so we don't actually need real bodies
and the doctors were like no there's
nothing like it there's no replacement
so thus begins the era of body donation
wait a minute is this the same as being
an organ donor
the answer is no i'm an organ donor i
mean this is my driver's license and
when i got my driver's license when i
was 16 i checked the box i want to be an
organ donor if someone needs a heart
transplant or a kidney and i suddenly
die of an accident i'm totally down with
giving my heart to somebody else so that
they can live absolutely but it turns
out that organ donation and giving your
body over to science are two totally
different things
okay so we have two categories here one
is the transplant category which is like
the organ donation it means removing
body parts that are going to be put back
into another living person this is what
i opted for by becoming an organ donor
on my driver's license let me just play
out the scenario of how this works using
my friend sheila
sheila is from texas she was in a bad
accident and had a traumatic brain
injury she's currently in the hospital
on life support and has zero brain
activity the hospital kind of knows
where this is going and so they call a
company called an organ procurement
company an opo and they tell them that
hey sheila's gonna die soon the opo
company verifies that sheila is on the
organ donor list they quickly connect
with her family to tell them that they
will be honoring her wishes by donating
her organs once she passes and then the
company asks sheila's family if they
would also allow her tissues to be
donated and the family inevitably
responds with tissues what do you mean
and they explain that in addition to her
organs they could also use her skin her
bones her eyes to help with all kinds of
medical devices and treatments they tell
sheila's family that one tissue donor
can heal the lives of more than 75
people so the family agrees once sheila
dies her heart lungs liver pancreas
intestines kidneys are all removed put
on ice and sent all around the country
to hospitals where people are in
desperate need of organs to stay alive
they've been sitting on a waiting list
for months or even years and today is
their day thanks to sheila and her
donation of her organs oh and this
happens really fast like within hours
because these organs can't stay alive
outside of a body for long then they
take out her tissues her heart valves
are sent to a nearby hospital to help
people with heart defects her skin is
sent to iowa to help reconstruct a
child's cleft palate her corneas are
sent to an eye bank in louisiana to help
restore eyesight and some of her body
fat tissue is sent to california to be
made into injectable lip fillers that
does that's not saving lives but yeah
that's a part of this too anyway back to
sheila after all of her organs and
tissues have been taken out of her and
sent around the country she gets
stitched up and returned to her family
where they can then bring her to a
funeral home and prepare her for her
funeral honestly it's a modern miracle
that we can even do this it saves tons
of lives every year and i'm totally down
with being an organ donor not really
into my fat being used as lip injections
but whatever i'm down with the system
now i want to talk about the other
category the non-transplant industry
this is the one that i've been thinking
a lot about lately and that i had no
idea existed until i started diving into
this video let me explain how it works
on this side of things and i'll do so
with my friend sean these are not real
people like sheila is not a real person
sean is not a real person these are
invented characters in the name of
explaining this process
thank you for your concern sean lives in
arizona he's at the end of his life and
he's at a hospice care one day someone
shows up to the hospice they are from a
non-transplant anatomical donation
organization or a nado or i'm just going
to call it a body broker body broker
person approaches sean and pitches this
idea that sean could donate his body to
science shawn responds with oh you mean
like becoming an organ donor i'm already
an organ donor says sean kind of says
the body broker guy but kind of
different they explain that sean can
leave a lasting legacy with his
anatomical gift that will train future
doctors these are real marketing terms
that body brokers use oh and best of all
sean there's no cost in donating in fact
the company will pay for a cremation so
that he doesn't have to this is starting
to sound really good to sean he likes
the idea of donating his body to science
and he's very aware that his family
doesn't really have the money to pay for
a proper funeral which can cost like six
to ten thousand dollars all that can be
covered by this body broker so he's into
it sean signs the papers tells his
family hey i'm not going to get buried
i'm going to donate my body to science a
few weeks later sean dies and the body
broker that shawn signed with comes and
picks up his body bring it to his
facility where they properly embalm it
and then they take it apart shawn is now
a cadaver a former body that exists now
in a dozen or so parts that sit in a
freezer are shipped around the country
and world for a variety of purposes his
head is rented to a university in
pennsylvania where medical students are
studying neuroscience it is then
returned and rented again to a
university in ecuador for the same
purpose shawn's foot is then rented to a
medical device company that makes screws
and plates for ankle surgery the company
has a new product a metal plate that
they want to show off to surgeons so
they send shawn's foot to a medical
conference in las vegas where they fly a
surgeon out first class and pay him to
demonstrate how this new device this
plate works on sean's foot a real
cadaver specimen they want the surgeons
to buy the plate his arm is then sold to
another medical device company in idaho
where they are testing a product that
helps with carpal tunnel it's not
approved yet but they're doing all this
r d and they use shawn's hand to run a
few more tests so that it can be
approved go on the market and make the
money his upper torso is sold to another
medical device company that is hosting
an all-inclusive event at a convention
center in san diego where they're
showing off their new titanium sternum
something they want surgeons to use so
they fly out all these surgeons they
give them food and drinks and
accommodations all of this paid for by
the medical device company their hope is
that these surgeons will have a good
time
see the product being used on a real
cadaver and leave wanting to use that
product in the next surgery a new
customer sean's remaining lower half is
sold to the department of defense
the u.s military and they use it in a
u.s army blast experiment where the u.s
army uses it to test the effects of a
new bomb on human tissue on a real human
body and after about a year and a half
what remains of sean is cremated and
those remains are sent back to the
family here's my issue with this sean
wanted to donate his body to science i'm
not sure he was exactly signing up to be
the test subject for a multi-million
dollar medical device industry but he
was helping science right medical
devices are science and his body was
used by students at a med school but did
sean know that that's what science was
defined as i mean that body on that
table in portland being dissected at the
oddities and curiosities expo that body
was obtained through this market through
this system was that science so this is
why i feel a little uneasy about this i
don't think this is a bad corrupt
industry i just think it has some
problems okay hold on i'm gonna bring
you over to my very messy desk so that
you can look at a couple of documents
with me okay so let me just make one
thing clear here i'm not trying to do
some expose on
cadavers in the cadaver industry like
this stuff helps people we can go into
an operating room and have a surgeon
operate on us knowing that they've
practiced on cadavers i am in total
support of that my issue with this
industry is much more with all of the
incentives the monetary incentives that
are baked into this market that lead to
some abuses let me explain what i mean
[Music]
the first thing i'm most concerned about
is the lack of regulation there's not a
lot of regulation on what these body
brokers have to divulge and explain to
the person who is donating their body
we've been documenting how these body
brokers market the idea of giving up
your body supporting medical research
advancements medical advancements
advances in medical and physician
training improvements in the quality of
life for generations to come no cost no
cost anatomical gift a powerful gift no
greater gift benefiting humanity and
providing hope for future generations
donate your body to science
this stuff is framed as an altruistic
donation to future generations and so
while there's real truth in that what we
don't see is the reality of what happens
after your body is donated when you have
a profit incentivized market and
companies often what you see is these
companies going to great lengths to get
their profits higher and higher one
thing we found in our reporting is these
body brokers have started working with
funeral homes so now they have an
arrangement where the funeral home will
get a kickback they'll get paid a
commission if they can sell
the grieving family on donating their
loved one's body to this body broker
reuters did some really good reporting
around this in 2017 and found dozens of
funeral homes that have this mutually
beneficial business relationship like
sales relationship with body brokers
this is exactly my issue with all of
this the funeral home now has an
incentive to push body donation onto
these families there's one guy who was
the head of a body broker who said he
wanted to build his business to be the
mcdonald's of body parts i did it that's
200 for me
now look we looked into a lot of these
body brokers some of them are sketchy a
lot of them are not we went through the
consent agreements for a ton of these
body burgers honestly a lot of these do
a really good job of painting an
accurate picture like this one from ohsu
in portland it makes you sign that you
understand that upon my death my body
will be embalmed dissected
disarticulated or plastinated for
permanent preservation part of these
procedures may take a small amount of
anatomical material recoverable or
destroyed in the process this is how it
should work there should be total
transparency but unfortunately that's
not how it happens all the time again
this is the wild west it is the free
market there is so little regulation
that anyone and i mean anyone can get
into the donation business so let me
explain to you the horror stories of
what happens in an unregulated market
where there's profit incentives viewer
discretion advised
the company violated everything they
promised this is just wrong on so many
levels chop shop for human body parts
illegally sold body parts against donors
wishes one company was cutting up bodies
with a chainsaw and not really tracking
where the bodies went the body parts
were never reunited and the cremated
remains that were given to the family
members may not be the cremated remains
the owner was eventually charged with
fraud but the charges were dropped
because there aren't any laws for this
here's another one that that reuters
investigation covered in 2015 there was
a neighborhood in southern nevada and
the neighbors were complaining about
like some foul smells as well as like
bloody boxes in the dumpsters so health
inspectors showed up and they found a
worker holding a garden hose thawing a
frozen human torso outside in the
afternoon sun there was like bits of
tissue and blood that were like being
washed into the neighborhood gutter like
what a nightmare but again because
there's no rules or laws here like
nothing could be done the last one i'll
tell you about and then i'll spare you
the rest happened in 2014 when the fbi
raided the biological resource center in
arizona and found what an agent called
various unsettling scenes
[Music]
i think we in the u.s love a good supply
and demand story but we have built a
market with the right incentives to
create so much supply that we actually
have an excess and we ship cadavers to
other countries speaking of other
countries i put a call out on instagram
to all of you in the rest of the world
that is not the united states asking how
you deal with cadavers what's the
culture around cadavers in your country
and i got some really cool responses
leon from croatia said that once the
cadavers are done being used for
research the remains are buried in this
famous beautiful tomb
sophie said that in austria there's a
ceremony to honor donated bodies that
their remains are buried in a mass grave
fabia told me that in portugal there's a
yearly ceremony in the medical community
to pay tribute to the bodies that were
used for learning the same thing happens
in canada according to ellen and then
there's taiwan yielding shay told me
that students refer to the cadavers as
their teachers and then there's a
memorial organized to honor them before
the first incision ever takes place
students will sometimes even visit the
families of the cadavers that they
worked on to like learn about the people
that they were thailand does something
similar people who donate their bodies
to science get a really honorable title
and then medical students and monks will
come together in a ceremony to pay
tribute to these people who gave their
bodies for science and learning when the
body has fulfilled its use and it's no
longer useful for learning they do a
cremation and have a ceremony to
thank these bodies even we'll
memorialize all of the donors names in
like a pamphlet to say like thank you
thank you for teaching us
so the question is this should you be
scared to donate your body and the
answer is absolutely not in the
beginning of this video i talked about
the situation of that world war ii
veteran being dissected in front of a
pain audience a horrible thing but again
i hope i made it clear that sort of
thing is not common in fact the body
broker who rented this body for the
event released a statement saying that
they were deceived most body brokers in
my view from what i've done in my
reporting
are ethical and transparent and are are
respectful but it's the few that take
advantage of the lack of regulation that
i think calls for more attention from
the government so that people can
actually feel confident in donating
their bodies and knowing that they're
going to go to actually advancing
scientific research and products i did
it that's 200
it's operation the wacky doctors game
where you're the wacky doctor so if i
were thinking about donating my body to
science what i would do is go to a
university and say hey do you have a
program where someone can submit their
body to be used in your research and if
they do you can be guaranteed that your
body will be used to train medical
students if you do decide to donate
through a for-profit company look to see
if that company has been certified by
the american association of tissue banks
which often means they've been vetted
they're not just like some rogue prophet
seeking person in fact if you want to go
on to the website of this association
you can find a body broker that is
accredited also read the documents all
these disclosures have a bunch of fine
print on how your body will be used if
you donate it oh and i just want to say
one last thing about organ donation
which is different than full body
donation only two percent of registered
organ donors like me end up successfully
donating their organs because the only
way that they can get my organs out and
get them transplanted into somebody else
is if i die in a hospital on a
ventilator that is why only two percent
of organ donors actually get their
organs procured so it's really important
that if you want to be an organ donor
you make sure you are signed up there
are a hundred thousand people right here
in the u.s right now who are waiting for
a transplant and the more donors there
are the more likely they will find a
match i'm gonna put links to resources
where you can learn more about organ
donation and whole body donation as well
as really good reporting by reuters and
the l.a times and others on this topic a
human body represents a life and it
deserves to be treated with respect no
matter if it's donated cremated or
buried my hope in making this video is
that you'll better understand what this
industry looks like why it exists why it
needs to be regulated and maybe you'll
consider participating in it because i
do believe that donating your body to
science can help improve our world and
honestly once my body dies i'm kind of
totally down with it having a renewed
purpose
i just want to know what that purpose is
and how it will be used
so
thank you for watching
so i want to welcome the hundreds of
thousands of new subscribers who have
come to this channel
in the past few weeks welcome um yes i
usually do international relations
topics but really what i do on this
channel is curiosity i'm a curious
person and i dive into things and i
learn about them and then i usually
share them with you and so that's what
this video is and there's a lot more to
come just a reminder that i have a
patreon for anyone who wants to support
patreon i have uh presets and luts which
is how i color my videos and photos i
have a storytelling course on brighttrip
which is a platform that i co-founded a
few years ago where i tell you all about
storytelling and my
view on
video storytelling with nathaniel drew
who's also another video storyteller so
those are a few things that are in the
description if you want to check them
out thank you all for being here and i
mean look at you you're at the very end
of this video like you are at the like
last few seconds of a very long video
and you're just still here that's
amazing so thanks for being here until
the very end see you